my uh fantasy series of course is is
often compared to Tolkien and and I love
Tolkien I'm a I'm the biggest fan in the
world of Lord of the Rings tolkien's
view of Good and Evil in that is is you
know evil is externalized it comes from
Sauron there are uh you know Orcs who
are absolutely irredeemable I've always
been more attracted to to Great
characters and I've said in many
interviews well I do think the Battle of
Good and Evil is a great subject for
fiction but in my view the Battle for
good and evil is waged within the
individual human heart and it's our
decisions we're all partly good and
partly evil we make decisions every day
and we may do a good thing on Wednesday
and then an evil thing on Thursday or a
selfish thing my version of Sauron was
the Crimson King that's outside evil and
in a way outside evil is a more
comforting concept than you know the
idea that the devil made me do it uh is
a way of shocking responsibility and
saying that I'm not there